claude blanchemaison à présent expert en
relations internationales
c'est l'édito de la matinale claude
blanchemaison bonjour bonjour heureux de
vous retrouver ce matin sur rtl france
alors est ce que on se dirige vers une
guerre civile en birmanie
malheureusement ça pourrait bien être le
cas parce que on a bien vu que au moment
du coup d'état
les militaires ont arrêté les principaux
dirigeants de la ligue nationale pour la
démocratie le parti de madame aung san
suu kyi même si san suu kyi elle-même
est en résidence surveillée
mais très vite on a vu les arrestations
se multipliaient
et puis surtout les manifestations la
population civile qui manifestent tous
les jours
beaucoup de jeunes qui se mobilisent des
des médecins les avocats des gens donc
appartenant à la société birmane et la
nouveauté peut être ces jours ci c'est
que les minorités ethniques qui sont au
nombre d'une douzaine en birmanie se
mobilise pas les rohingya naturellement
puisqu'ils ont été chassés par la junte
militaire il ya deux ans mais des
minorités comme les carènes et d'autres
minorités qui dans le passé ont déjà eu
maille à partir avec les militaires au
pouvoir
et certaines de ces minorités sont
organisées pas vraiment armé mais elles
sont capables de mener des actions et
elles sont en train de rechercher la
coordination avec les manifestants et
ceci évidemment et est un stade et un
stade eu un petit peu inquiétant de la
tournure des événements puisque comme
vous l'avez dit les militaires d
on utilise des tirs à balles réelles et
que parmi les 1 100 morts qui qui ont
été tués au cours des deux derniers mois
beaucoup l'ont été par des tirs à balles
réelles
y compris des femmes des enfants aiment
apparemment des bébés donc ceci suscite
une émotion considérable dans dans le
monde et et il est possible en effet que
ceux-ci dégénère en guerre civile
actuellement parfaitement asymétrique
puisque les militaires birmans sont très
bien armés ce qui n'est pas le cas de la
population alors on a vu que l'otan à la
russie s'est dite inquiète les pays
occidentaux montent au créneau y at il
un certain embarras des des grandes
puissances face à ce qui se passe en
birmanie
je crois que c'est le mot un embarras un
embarras parce que la birmanie est un
pays très important et on voit bien que
les pays occidentaux
bien sûr soutiennent madame aung san suu
kyi
le parti et son parti que il condamne le
coup d'état mais on voit bien aussi que
la russie à certains bras vous l'avez
décrit tout à l'heure qu'elle condamne
les violences
bien sûr compte tenu des liens
historiques avec la birmanie
elle a envoyé un vice-ministre défense à
la fête nationale de l'armée samedi
dernier qui marquait 67e anniversaire de
la libération de l'occupation japonaise
c'est important parce que il faut
évidemment parler aux militaires et leur
faire comprendre que ils sont
probablement dans une voie sans issue en
pratiquant une répression sans limite
la chine est également embarrassé elle a
fait des déclarations pour dire que en
effet il fallait que les violences
cessent qu'il fallait que le dialogue
s'instaure et la chine est très
préoccupée puisqu'il est le principal
partenaire économique de la birmanie et
que certains manifestants s'étaient
tournés ces derniers temps vers les
investissements chinois
les usines chinoises ont été brûlés
et ceci inquiète particulièrement pékin
alors on va bien voir ce qui se passe au
conseil de sécurité des nations-unies
demain il est probable qu on s'orientera
vers un texte de résolution qui
condamnera la violence sans condamner
spécifiquement les militaires parce que
la chine s'y opposera que probablement
cette résolution préconisera le dialogue
mais la négociation du texte même va
durer elle va durer probablement
plusieurs jours parce que ça va être
très compliqué alors que les intérêts ne
sont pas exactement les mêmes
alors claude quel est l'effet de tous
ces événements sur les voisins de la
birmanie
l'inquiétude parce que ces événements
pour provoque évidemment des départs des
migrations alors déjà le bangladesh a
reçu les rohingya il ya deux ans
lorsqu'ils ont été chassés par l'armée
c'est une minorité musulmane et qu'il
faut les accueillir
or le magret de celle à l'épée il ait pu
les plus pauvres du monde
certains sirops inka ont migré en inde
qui ne veut pas à les conserver
monsieur n'à rennes ramolli l'adie est
en effet notre grand voisin à part la
chine c'est l'un alors l'un des très
embarrassée parce que l'inde est un pays
démocratique où il ya des élections
d'ailleurs monsieur narendra modi appris
il ya une dizaine de jours par un sommet
en vidéoconférence avec le président
biden le président biden avec le premier
ministre japonais être les ministres sud
coréen ce qu'on appelle le quad quatre
pays qui ont des régimes démocratiques
et qui veulent coopérer aussi sans doute
pour faire pièce à la montée en
puissance de la chine
mais en même temps là ne veut pas
laisser le terrain libre à l'influencé
chinoise en birmanie et par conséquent
inde a également envoyé un représentant
samedi dernier à la fête de l'armée a
lapidé dans la capitale
dans la capitale birmane et on voit bien
que l'inde qui a un territoire très
proche de la birmanie
les îles nicobar et à dahmane est
particulièrement inquiète de ce qui se
passe dans ce pays voisin avec lequel
elle a des liens traditionnels
merci beaucoup claude pour votre analyse
et on vous retrouve évidemment pour
votre édito de politique internationale
à mardi prochain dans la matinale